because there's some people in the  manosphere that think that  if a guy cheats you should try to work  it out because it could have just meant  nothing to him but if a girl cheats it's  the relationship is over but that's what  we're talking about though for me if a  guy cheats on me it's over there is no  way to come back when a guy cheats the  goal is never better looking than his  girlfriend and this is the point I was  gonna make before because the guy  doesn't wanna the guy doesn't actually  wanna it's gonna sound so mad the guy  doesn't actually want to leave his  girlfriend he doesn't want to fall in  love with another girl he act in a weird  way the guy who still loves his  girlfriend and the back of his mind  doesn't actually want to leave her or  love someone else so the girl who cheats  on is usually Never As Good as his  actual girlfriend